[Music]
very exciting you know what this means
right today only 28 more shopping days
till we go off the fiscal cliff isn't
that great
[Music]
to put your arms up
makes it more fun it's not a roller
coaster
[Applause]
hey i got good news twinkies may be
saved at the last minute the
manufacturer of tasty cakes is thinking
of buying the company that makes
twinkies and hohos
[Music]
so it looks like christmas came early
for stoners everywhere
yes
i see i see some of you made it here
they don't know where they are
this isn't dr phil
you you can tell where they are from the
rappers that yeah exactly
yesterday
yesterday the kid from the show two and
a half men actor angus t jones
said he wants to leave the show because
it goes against his christian values
yeah which by the uh way is the same
reason charlie sheen left
true story
a third man a third man has accused the
elmo puppeteer
of engaging in underage sex
yeah which explains why this christmas
sesame street's replacing their tickle
me elmo with may i see some id elmo
[Laughter]
seriously
street issued
in a new interview bill clinton said
that during his entire presidency he
only sent two emails
two
yeah however over two million white
house emails were sent from somebody
named bonerprez69
[Applause]
[Music]
today
at the speaker of the house john
boehner's office a group of nude female
protesters stormed in
yeah boehner said he's not sure what
they're protesting but he'll definitely
keep doing it
gotta mention this air new zealand air
new zealand has unveiled a hobbit-themed
airplane
of course real hobbit fans only fly
virginia
[Applause]
[Music]
although the in-flight entertainment on
virgin is fantastic
you guessed it
are you getting money from them
you get a little something on the side
from virgin
no no i wish
i was depressed about something
hey gang check out this one
i want to use that instead of any real
transition from now on yeah yeah hey
gang gather round i've got a new one see
it's the 1920s yeah
mexico's new president said that his
country's problems with the u.s are not
just about drugs and security issues
yeah he said it's really about america's
insistence that taco bell is mexican
food
i'm upset about that
and i gotta mention this a new study i
don't know about this it just came out
and this study shows that porn actresses
porn actresses have higher self-esteem
than other women
yeah the study was conducted by a guy
who's trying to talk his girlfriend into
making a sex tape
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you